hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is
r u garbage it's a show we sit down with
your favorite comedians we find out they
grew up to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host holy coming at you
on a rainy afternoon
post saint patrick's day down here at
aunt tooty's basement i don't know what
she got into last night
but there is a police horse in the
living room oh god
all right it was dicey as getting a bowl
of cereal this morning i could tell you
that
ah that one really
they're never going to stop right here
he writes he's by himself folks
i hear him when you do okay i wouldn't
have approved that one
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me
he has uh made some shady moves over the
last couple of days he's changed
vehicles
he's flying his girlfriend out of the
country there's been some
life my girlfriend's staying huh
gang he's my best friend in the whole
wide world the next time you're reaching
for a best pal go ahead and make it a
kippy give it up for kevin james ryan
hey gang i know you're trying to get
some brownie points because you're
brought back making a kippy
that's been that's been absent for a
little while he's been mad at me
what's up gang as always thanks for
tuning in please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and follow what are
those numbers
they're true to roof to [ __ ] roof and
then patreon.com the bread and butter
baby you can sign up to get premium
content of ayg
uh you get episodes of hard feelings
which is me and fully [ __ ] on each
other it's a good time
it's the breakout hit of 2021 everybody
loves it um
and then uh every month with our top
tier patrons we do a live stream and
then also
an even bigger news we got two big dates
we're pushing yes we do but you know
what they are
we got raleigh good night's april 20th
there in north carolina and then april
21st we're going over to zany
nashville and doing the show yeah guys
pick up a couple of tickets
will you if you're in if you're if
you're in with it like an eight-hour
drive we gotta move some [ __ ] tickets
down there and i'm already getting [ __ ]
that they ain't moving
so sign up go get tickets get some pals
get some your [ __ ] mom whoever you
gotta do
uh we'd love to see it's gonna be
something there's gonna be some stand up
we're gonna be playing ayg with the
crowd it's gonna be a good time you'll
ask us questions we'll ask you questions
we'll see you there it's gonna be fun
and a quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the pride of the chicago
comedy scene chicago
kid needs a haircut i'll tell you that
right now t-bone
mcmuffin dopey mcmullen i need a haircut
you need a career
damn [ __ ] took the gloves off today
well i need a
career because i need to make money
that's zany's nashville folks gang
speaking of breakout hits of the season
uh we could not be more excited to have
our incredibly special guest here with
us today
he's one of our oldest and dearest
friends we started in philly together
we've lived together we [ __ ] slugged
it out here in new york city
for years i always said he's the most
naturally funny naturally talented one
out of the group uh problem is pretty
much an idiot
but it doesn't matter turn the lights on
because the kid's a [ __ ] star he's
doing absolutely
fantastic he had a huge part on insecure
last season and everybody freaked out
everybody loved
he's got a lot of big things coming up
do me a favor give me a nice big round
of applause
for our good friend mr reggie congrats
yeah
i was waiting
[Laughter]
i'm so used to getting yelled at like
from all the podcasts we used to do
for the listener we had we used to have
a podcast the three of us along with uh
andrew chavone
and tom cassie was at the center city
conference two years
two years we had about three listeners
too it was pretty good
i remember we got it on itunes and
reggie goes damn we're on itunes
i'm telling you used to be like being on
world star like world star
back in the day it felt like you made it
being on being on itunes i was like oh
[ __ ] he's like kev we're really on
itunes i'm like anybody can get on
itunes
you're getting your ass beat in the
parking lot
[Laughter]
we know most of it but what is the what
is the straight through
origin story of reggie conquest uh i
started in philly i knew he was gonna
[ __ ] this
uh walked in downstairs and uh i took
the elevator i texted him
he said he said the fourth floor and uh
now we're here we started at the laugh
house now we're here
you're from west philly right west
philly uh west oakland
area and yeah i started comedy in philly
i used to
go to the raven lounge with you guys
yeah yeah you idiot
when you were born and [ __ ] like that
when you were oh you want to start oh
like
back there okay mom and dad brothers
okay mom and dad
met dad was a bus driver at the time and
uh
yeah we we they made me i don't know how
to introduce myself i'm sorry
i don't you like how far you want me to
go i do
do y'all ask everybody like that yeah
okay yeah i know i know so yeah it
started in west philly and i
started commenting i got five sisters
and uh i got a one brother
i don't i don't know i don't know how
far i love you
oh it's so funny five sisters
five sisters is that on your dad's side
of your mom's side or is it that's how
dad was getting busy
right damn huh you're
you're you're the only child between
your mom and your dad yeah right and
yeah who your brother
is my brother is my mom's um son not
you're
not your dad no my brother my dad got
all girls and me that's funny he's like
tall like your dad your brother
he's like a big dude like no i'm a i'm
i'm my dad's taller than me
but that's a bad look he's a bad dude i
know he's crazy
looking dude his facebook picture haunts
my dreams for the folks out there he's a
retired philadelphia police officer
and i would not have wanted to done
anything wrong
dude i would yeah that would have been a
bad luck he jacked some dudes up
he's still got it too he's got the gray
beard and i'm like
damn i hope it reminds me of roy jones
jr a little bit he's just like
yeah he's got [ __ ] he's got i hope i
get that like when i'm 16
you're not gonna happen if you don't
have it now you're not gonna get it
no i think
[Laughter]
you don't grow into being smooth you're
not gonna be able to pull off a pair of
stacy adams the way he does yeah
i know that's the only thing i haven't
got from him like that he rocks like
that style that swag
i just like like a delivery
[Laughter]
he dressed like an uber driver yeah like
i can't pull it off
i i really hope i age into that though
odd buddy i think i don't think you're
you're go
you're just going to be this older
you're going to be 66 wearing [ __ ]
hoodies and [ __ ]
that's the worst old
i thought about that how trashy are like
retirement homes going to look at in
like 40 years
everybody's in woo where ever i got all
yeezys
sitting around on a weezer t-shirt some
90 year old yeah like my dad my dad
looked cool as [ __ ] and
when his old pictures he had he had kids
he had a house he
always was stocky and i'm just like i'm
stocky up top up here
i'm good dude there's an old picture of
you for when you first start i think
when you first
started doing comedy you had that like
the tan blazer on i think yeah oh
dude he looks dude you literally look
like you're wearing shoulder pads
you look like you're about to start a
linebacker and you're at the club
like what the [ __ ] is he doing that's
how i thought i had to dress when i
first started
like a bouncer like said like said the
entertainer like that's who i wanted to
that's what i thought i had to dress up
to do stand up
if you look back at a lot of those
pictures i'm guilty of it too what we
thought we were supposed to look like as
comedians yeah it was atrocious i think
i
before my first show i think i googled
what's a comedian wearing
remember the one with me in the suit and
the sweater my hands were sticking out i
don't think i don't think anybody
sitting here looks good in a suit
no i i i i with a decent cut i there's
one cut from h m that i look
okay in i i look horrible
you look like you belong in a cat scary
[Laughter]
after two seconds the shirts i look like
a fat kid at the end of a wedding
literally i should have [ __ ] cake on
my face running around
i look like a like a uber black driver
sorry i'm late come on hop in come on
like let's go
like yeah i look bad yeah are you henry
real that's why i'm all about the uh the
non-tuck-in shirt with the suit
yeah that's up too but that's [ __ ]
that's that's like a fat kid wearing a
shirt in a pool everybody knows what
you're doing no no just tuck your shirt
in and keep it [ __ ] moving you're not
everybody knows you're here especially
at weddings when it comes time to take
the jacket off
i can't tell just a dress shirt i can't
not
tuck my shirt in like my shirt has to be
out at rose wedding my shirt was out
remember i showed up with that floyd
shirt where's his shoe jacket
dude he showed up like he was going into
a [ __ ] you know studio 56 or
something
trying to pull off his dad's look yeah i
am i am my dad can pull it off no jacket
jacket
because he yeah yeah he's cool and in
shape
remember speaking of monroe's wedding
remember that dude that was in the
[ __ ] nike sweatsuit yeah he showed up
with a nike
dude that dude had no i there was like
[ __ ] 25 comics just sitting there
crushing him
dude he had a matching nike sweatsuit on
and people were like posting up on them
and [ __ ]
i would imagine you've worn some some
suspect clothing items to
friends weddings and stuff i i i i'm all
black t-shirt like if i can wear a black
t-shirt to everything
i would with a jacket
the blazer the old blazer look no i'm
with you that's the t-shirt blazer
magnum pi yeah miami vice style that's
all they did was just weird
it's not i get it i've i've definitely
tried to pull it off but you need the
right jacket
otherwise you just look like a fat kid
and a t-shirt with a suit jacket you
know what i mean like
that guys it's a tough look
dude i bought a suit recently what did i
have to wear a suit to
i don't know i had to wear a suit to
something dude oh my cousin's wedding
dude
[ __ ] i ordered it [ __ ] got my
measurement when you got to order
yourself oh
dude i still look like [ __ ] it was like
three o'clock it looked like it was
midnight
it was just a mess you got your tie
undone
the last thing the last two weddings i
went to it's been shirt and
nice pair of shoes
i don't know what she's missing out on
oh i look so bad i i can't stand
the formal i just look bad you gotta you
gotta have someone
do it for like you can find a look
that's cheap
and relative and you look good and you
feel comfortable in it's tough to do
but you can do it i don't know sounded
like the guy from the men's wear
you're going to like the way you look i
guarantee you all of you look like
valets when you put a suit on
i i got i can look okay at best
it's nice full body suit was prom that
was the last time i think i woke up you
know he's tragic because he caught it a
full body suit
[Laughter]
those are less full bodies
it's a suit a full body that's it
all white wait was it long though it was
low
my dad had his new we had a new my dad
got his new he had a new
ford explorer 2009.
pull up in that yes did your dad drive
you no i drove
nice i was thinking about that the other
day i drove to my prom too i remember
being such a big deal
like we got the car cleaned yeah all
this stuff
y'all you use the family car
yeah that dog was in the back
wait you didn't you didn't rent a car
like you didn't get a new car you just
used to
rent a car for the prom yeah that's what
you're supposed to do i got a [ __ ]
nissan maximus sitting in the driveway
no nuts you took the took the [ __ ] out
the car
cleaned it up and went to prom and
nissan yeah why is that garbage
you're either supposed to rent a car you
just said you got your dad no no but it
was brand new
yeah i'll give you this dude you can't
you can't be taking like the [ __ ]
like the gym bag out of the back seat to
put your [ __ ]
three of a prom date just move my dad's
racquetball stuff
i got cigarette cigarette butts you
gotta move
there's that there's empty bag of
mcdonald's i think that's a white prom
thing though like you guys don't do the
we did limo we always did like a big
like he did he was driving it
gippy you're good wait so everybody got
in the back uh yeah it would be like
a couple most of my friends got duis
that night too they all drove themselves
as well that seems like super old school
driving yourself to prom that's
yeah i think that that is that is that
was like in the movies in like the 80s
and like hey dad can i borrow the car
like that kind of thing that air is dead
yeah yeah yeah you got it you got to
[ __ ]
dude also it dropped when we our age it
was very
like hip-hop was like those call you had
to be in a nice car
absolutely so it was like you pull up in
like a [ __ ] navigator my prom was so
packed
i had all f's i had all f's going on
prom
the block was everybody was there i came
down that's so fresh and so clean
you came down to a theme song oh my god
yes
what oh my god where in your house i'm
upstairs you get dressed or whatever
everybody's downstairs with pictures and
stuff like that
you're getting married graduation you're
[ __ ] snow white
no this is every every black person i
know comes down to music
so you wear that you wait at the top of
the steps
and they play your music and you come
down the steps and then people take
pictures of you
and then and then you go pick up the
girl same thing she's got music
they got to start three days ahead of
time
it's good i've never heard it wait so
y'all didn't come down to music you
don't really
calm down even though i we rented a limo
and we would all this
is bananas dude we would all meet at
someone's house my mom dropped us off on
the way to the grocery store
we would all meet at someone's house
whoever had like a big nice
yes house nicest house yeah whoever had
the biggest nicest house
who wants to go to somebody's nice house
on our special
went to the senior prom three times i
definitely had all f's
i somehow graduated on time
i was a d student going on prom i feel
like
with the theme song dude if you got it
all left at least fly below the radar
another one bites the dust my aunts and
[ __ ] handed me money guys
thanks dad thanks for flipping your
money too they thought they give you
money
you get you get a little book they it's
great it's a little book
like the book the sign oh no that's the
yearbook i'm getting it mixed up but
they give you
they give you they give you prime money
y'all don't yeah first of all they they
you get money though
your parents give you money not for
problem no problem
maybe like here's 20 bucks in case you
need something in case you go to burger
king with
20 bucks
reggie's in the [ __ ] auditorium
making it rain
auditorium okay oh it was yours wait
y'alls wasn't y'all
y'all had your prime in auditorium no no
ours was at the
constitution center in philly it was
like oh yeah yeah same same yeah
i was about to say auditorium arthur's
in the cast
jesus
our semi-formal was was in the cafeteria
what the following folly's [ __ ] slow
dancing with a six next to a folded up
lunch table
foley's prom had a bowl of punch
marty mcfly was playing everybody's
dancing paul was getting down on a
salisbury steak
molly's back in the refrigerator
everybody's on speed
what's dude you gotta you gotta come
down you never know what you're gonna
get with reggie
oh i love it no i didn't know i didn't
know prom money was net wasn't a thing
no prom money an intro song was never a
thing okay so
let me where'd you go after prom like
did you do something the day after
or yeah the night after we would
typically go to like a house party or
something i think we might have went
down the shore the one night
like we went down to one time
where'd you guys go aruba what the [ __ ]
going on we had hard drugs getting out
of my system
i needed some [ __ ] rest i ain't going
anywhere no we so
we went to ihop first
[Laughter]
got kicked out this is real [ __ ] we went
to ihop
in our prom show after after prom after
prom yeah go to uh
you [ __ ] dork you didn't go to a
party and get [ __ ] up we went to a
strip club
and this is this is this is night on
broadway in philly it's a very
rinky-dink [ __ ] you took your dates
there
no our dates left and we went to the
strip club and i had three hundred
dollars
gotta spend it wait a minute why didn't
you go out with your date afterwards and
hook up with her
well as a i went to a couple proms i
went to two
i went to three problems i went to one
with my sister you what wait you went to
a prom with your sister as a date yeah
as a date
and she was a she was a she was in 12th
i was in 10th
and then my then when i went i went with
that's bananas
that's [ __ ] but you went to the same
school
huh you guys go to the same high school
yeah but i was like in like 10th grade
so you would have been in the school
with her yeah i was in school with her
but i was in like 10th grade so i
to took her you went to the prom with
your sister
yeah is that normal what's going on
that's not normal
that is normal no not people where in
utah
that's not normal my sister's my friend
i can go to the prom with my sister
dude no you can't i'm sorry people do
that all the time no
no i guarantee you they do not did you
both get your own entrance song or do
they play two
i don't think my sister's not it came
out you guys came out the [ __ ] dx
song
my sister's prom was totally different
from mine my [ __ ] was turnt up
yeah you ended up at ihop with no broads
sounds real turned up
so i went to one where i went all right
i wore all black
she had a red dress on my sister and
then i would
you
i'm gonna post the pictures though but i
got the i got the pr the picture were
all black
and then buddy you went to the prom with
your sister
that was her
it wasn't my problem she brought me to
her prom let me ask you this you should
have put your foot down inside yeah i'm
not going to probably
no it was fun it was good we had a good
time why did she take her little brother
got my little worm wet got my little
noodles sucked
i can't believe it i didn't want to say
it
i was waiting i thought of it four
minutes i was waiting for
[Laughter]
it took every fiber of my baby
hey gang real quick want to talk about
the good time that old uncle hank and
the kipster are having there on the
stereo app
we're having a fun time answering your
questions get involved today
yeah guys we'll see you there every week
it's a little bit of an after party an
after show a q a you guys ask us your
garbage questions live on air on the
live stream it's your voice going out to
everybody
um and then we answer we have fun i have
a couple of cocktails you know relax at
the end of the week a little bit
you know it's a little bit of my happy
hour uh so go to www.stereo.com
kevin ryan or slash h foley the link's
in the description you can sign up we
get to wet our beaks a little bit it's a
good time we'll see you there
now back to the show
trying to [ __ ] on me that's crazy but
the the the the
why did your sister take you to is that
a black guy is that because white
that's that's i think that's normal i
think not does that no
it's not nobody i've ever had
listeners right in nobody i've ever
known race creed color doesn't matter
went to a prom with their sister or
brother
okay that's i know a couple people to
have but she took me unless there was
something wrong with one of them
did they think you were slow or
something
alright no one's going to ask reggie
i'll take him
[Laughter]
so i don't know i don't think she's got
a neck brace on
i don't know why i don't know i can't
remember why i went maybe she didn't
have a date or he cancelled on her or
whatever
that's what it was somebody cancelled
that makes sense so that that's what i'm
saying
that's normal that sweet you stepped up
and yeah yeah so i took i was in 10th
class
don't give him this if some dirtbag
stood her up
yeah so yeah he stood her up or she
couldn't have a date or something
but i went to her prom and then my
senior year no this is [ __ ]
she's just a [ __ ]
nobody wants to [ __ ] her right he's like
all right tag me and so
wrong i'm sorry so
so then that was her problem then my
senior year i i took a date
and then i graduated you preached over
that real quick
was it your brother no no it was it was
a girl i was dating at the time
i took there you go and then i graduated
and then the girl i was dating another
girl i was dating that was in 11th grade
that was a senior
i came back and went to her brother look
at you that's that's relatively normal
like in part two i like it yeah coming
back so i went through all the
do you remember the songs your intro
songs hold on did you get an intro song
when you took the girl when you went
back like when you were out of high
school or is that just a one-and-a-half
no
no that was a one-time thing because
that that your senior year yeah that was
mine
you can't you can't have an entrance to
a [ __ ] prom that you don't even go to
no my senior prom with one i had all d's
and i was graduating
i had intro music everybody was there
all these
aunts giving me money now when i came
back and took her it was
her song so yeah you just low and laid
was working at the high school at the
time was the lunch lady bull
i see it's monday i can't believe
you guys uh don't never heard of that
what taking a sibling on a no
never other than that situation
yeah i mean that's like something from a
movie i think that was on friends or
something like that
i feel like everybody didn't somebody
stand up uh yeah then ross tried to jump
in for
uh or like i know what the [ __ ] happens
in france
what the [ __ ] did that happen on black
ish
i had a serious conversation with my
friends i'm like what
the king of queens maybe i would have
got it
i would have stepped right in on king of
queens arthur went to the prom
oh yeah i don't know i don't want to be
friends at all
shout out shout out to giga queens
that little hour at night i get was just
king of queens i watch it every time
it's like white martin
it is it's like my white martin they
tried to call seinfeld that like no
king of queens is it for me
all right we got to get to some
questions here uh i'll just recap
because you were incapable of doing it
so you were born and raised in west
philadelphia
yes you're right i don't know what the
hell to say either
and now we're here i mean there's an
interesting backstory there your dad was
married he had an affair
no he was never married why are you
hearing about his [ __ ] dirty laundry
you [ __ ] dark
it's because he said affair you got real
[ __ ]
real mari on us i almost punched
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you
[Laughter]
i guarantee you said something about him
and sheila i'm gonna die
an affair jesus christ so he was an
adulterer correct
he was a womanizer correct what
oh god i need a minute
oh my head hurts
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right dude that just killed dude
your reaction to him
really affair really hits me it pissed
me off
i'm sorry he don't talk like that
oh okay
side piece cheated i'm like yeah
affair adultery what
i'm sorry so you've been in europe for
three years
i blacked out for a second i thought i
was going to pass out
oh okay all right been in new york for
what
nine years no is that eight seven eight
nine
how long you been here i think seven you
and i have both been here
three of us have been here for seven
years you came up six months i've been
saying nine years
i moved here in 2013 yeah so did we we
moved
here on the same day oh okay so
2013 it's 20 21.
i've been saying nine years old it'll be
seven years in
it'll be eight years in july
because i'm seven years in i know we
came up in january that's what i'm
saying we came up here before kids yeah
it came up six months six months
okay that's a year dude all right i
apologize
i was trying to get some i was trying to
get them to have some sort of you know
back story we're fine yeah um
yeah i've been here seven years now
uh you know minus the pandemic i ran
back to philly
well you were in la for the first half
of it yeah i was in l.a for the first
half
sad as [ __ ] i remember he called him and
i was like yes
[Laughter]
wait what i was just saying i would
start i started out in la
when the before the pandemic i was out
in l.a and
then the pandemic happened i was like
all right i'm out of here yeah good
good [ __ ] i don't want to be here you
went out there for work
yeah it was a pressure situation
everything started shutting down i'm
like i'm gonna die
in l.a i was so happy to come back
oh man i was scared of [ __ ] in that ella
that uh er
that airline airport yes oh and that was
like in the beginning of it when
everybody yeah one [ __ ]
i didn't i didn't even like people
looking at me when did you fly back from
l.a
um probably in march oh you did also
right oh man that was like the beginning
i was in elephant i wasn't
getting that death
[Laughter]
so scared we didn't know which way it
was coming either we had gloves on masks
on
[ __ ] sunglasses you didn't know where
it was going to get you
brutal so yeah i've been here me and
foley were roommates
oh which by the way for the i don't know
if i think we might have touched it on
this at some point
he has you went out was the one of the
funniest stories you went out and
bought all the food and then what was it
the eggo waffles or the texas toast or
something
oh yeah yeah and waffles yeah red you
went out and bought a big thing of eggo
waffles
and this maniac opens up the box from
the back so in the freezer it optically
looks like the box is still sealed but
for the whole week
he's been stealing waffles out of the
back of the box
and he flips so it's like a trap door
we call that the back of the truck
technique
dude in the business i get all my food
you know him and cotton are living in
the wood
cotton it was me cotton and then a
friend of ours who whose parents had the
lease
that poor sorry it was a one bedroom by
the way there was nine [ __ ]
literally
we kind of muscled our way in there took
the place over
[ __ ] eating baked potatoes out of the
microwave cotton's cabbage remember yeah
dude he literally we had nothing he
seasoned that with salt and toothpaste
and it was [ __ ] phenomenal it's like
literally there was nothing in it
i remember asking is there butter in
this she's like no i'm like egg is there
cheese he's like no
he just made some of the best cabbage
ever
[ __ ] awesome but yeah fully fully
would eat a lot of
my [ __ ] that i didn't really hold on for
the record you went to the store
once and you got stuff for like a winter
but i just remember you like two weeks
later being like all that was left was
the
waffles you're like here we go i'm gonna
have waffles every meal
there is one empty one left in a bag one
waffle left in a clear bag
was probably [ __ ] frost bit and [ __ ]
i was so upset
oh man that was that place had uh
i i lost weight there because because
the chickens were so
sad you know it's bad you usually eat
the roommate there would keep all his
food in this
yeah and because he knew if he put it
into that living room
it was over oh man it was like a grocery
store in belarus
this is [ __ ] empty shells little
creatine powder
oh my god trying to find something in
there late at night starving was
difficult
billion cube soup that little uh futon
out there
and your room you can hear everything in
foley's room whatever he's watching
listening to i'm like oh foley's home
all right let's get into some more you
garbage questions yeah um
so you were in la you were here and now
you're now you're living in philly
right now okay um that sucks
let's go over some stuff let's do some
of the basics yeah let's do some of the
basics
from jump street what was the name of
the street that you grew up on
felton felton street avenue melton
street yeah
felton street fountain street felton
yeah we used to go get dimes down there
in high school that was like the
felton street felton street yeah 322
north fountain street
sounds like the nice part
holy [ __ ] all right uh what was the
supermarket that sheila would go to
growing up save a lot
save a lot yeah i don't think i've ever
been to one well there's a reason for
that
you don't live on felton street yeah or
as we called it dimebag alley
uh yeah save a lot it was a little
market on the corner we uh it was a
little asian market i forgot the name of
it but we used to go in there and steal
[ __ ] all the time
reggie's a big crook by the way and he's
always he's got sticky feet well i stop
now i don't do it anymore
did sheila every time you walked into a
7-eleven with reggie you came up with 15
things
i used to always warn you against it too
there's other comics that do it
in the airport in the airport a lot of
people steal from the airport yeah
yeah i stole a pillow or two from here
pillow you never stole a neck pillow
it's so easy to take one and just keep
walking right he's like i stole a
sunglass hut on my way back from
the way back from l.a i'm definitely
taking a pillow from the airport
holy [ __ ] just just walk right by
casually
keep it on you're getting on a flight
with a massage chair
you're gonna have to check that right in
the middle of the aisle
yeah people do steal from the airport
but yeah i know and i always said is
that that's not something you want to
get pinched for then you got to deal
with that no but i always
when i did steal my my little stealing
spree i took small stuff
candy bars you know you ever got caught
not and not not since i've been living
in new york yeah
yeah so i always had a plan if i got
caught like i got it cause i
you know what is i always have the money
but it's something about well not always
whoa that made me think of a story uh
one time we were at the 7-11
in the west village it was real late at
night reggie was in there he had no
money he was just casing a joke
he was just circling and he happened to
catch uh
one of the like one of the cashiers they
were changing out the donuts oh yeah
remember
she was throwing them out yeah right in
front and she wouldn't give him a
doughnut
yeah and he was in there pleading with
her
everyone that would that's 7-eleven when
they're not paying attention i'm walking
right out
they always in there fighting with
somebody he's always at that place is a
scene
yeah i would go to the register i'll
look i'll go all right
i tried yeah i was bummed that mickey
these clothes
i used to hit that place all the time
that place was always too dirty for me
number one
oh yeah they always did have hot
cashiers in there they were dudes
yeah i think they were always uh gay
dudes is what he was referring to yeah
oh okay that place was a scene in there
it was
during the party girl during the day it
was normal it was nice
who's going to that mcdonald's yeah i'm
not going down today
i think they opened a minute i was
working at the bear burger around the
street so
every time i see fully in the village
randomly i'm like he's getting
some [ __ ]
when we were roommates we would just be
walking we doing ah now i'm out here
it's like three in the morning all right
man we're going home i'll catch up to
you
it's an hour away the train comes every
half an hour
one night he he gave me cash from
his like waiting tables job he had like
[ __ ] 300 bucks on him
or he had like 300 and let's say 60
bucks so he takes 60 bucks and keeps it
in his pocket use kippy
hold this 300 under no circumstances do
you give me this 300 bucks
i go all right man and i'm not even
joking 12 minutes later
give me the [ __ ] money dude he's like
i'm [ __ ] serious i need it right now
give me the [ __ ] money i'm like
okay this was fun that was at niagara
yeah i get those ipas in me
man oh niagara i remember everybody used
to get [ __ ] up in there killed
it was like a dollar for 40 beers for
like two years or something
wait what was that other one across the
street from atlanta that we i got kicked
out of
grizzly pear no not 206. 206. oh that
one
you were in the bathroom with some girls
during the show
they banned me from well dude it's a
dump first of all the viking
the bathroom was smaller than an
airplane bathroom and reggie at his
biggest is in there with the girl that
was bigger
they were [ __ ] stuck they had to get
an engineer to get him out of there
your friend your friend's in the
bathroom that's what the [ __ ] that
owner was saying
put that little latch on the door yeah
it was like a hook block
you could open it halfway and see
that came out you never come back you're
done you never walked in here i was like
all right [ __ ]
never bought anything in this dump
anyway
[Laughter]
oh man oh okay all right let's center
ourselves a bit let's get focused here
all right i have some i have some random
questions i'd like to know
um do you like any of the following
smells
fresh asphalt what is it
fresh asphalt reggie's immune to are you
garbage
i can't tell if he's a genius or an
idiot
he's deflected every one of our
questions
i haven't deflected anything he doesn't
understand one question
i feel like i'm talking to mr bean over
here
[ __ ] peter sellers all right what's
the next one
have you ever gone to prom with your
sister
garbage that's garbage it's not classy
um what'd you get on your sats
[Music]
what didn't i barbecue
did you i literally did that dude i did
a b hat
what yeah that's literally all i did i
literally remember like
the last last portion of just being like
[ __ ] this
then my friends was trying to racist you
can be finished
you tried to leave early they're like no
you can't you at least have to stay here
20 minutes
act like you're taking this car still
right oh my [ __ ] head hurts dude
i got a cab outside ladies
i got to pick up my problem with this i
got to do my choreography for my intro
uh oh prom what s.a.t
do you guys remember that yeah 11 40.
[Laughter]
you remember yours toby dude like 980.
oh okay mine was probably like a seven
something
don't you get like 800 points for
signing your name probably that's what
they say is that real
no yeah i don't think it's a real if it
is i [ __ ] that up
hate schmoly um uh growing up would you
drink milk with dinner
absolutely not yeah really absolutely
not i think that's a white thing
that is yeah did you have it so white
where would you
when would you have milk with cereal
that's it
they got
[Laughter]
today before i came yeah cause you're a
[ __ ] lunatic
with milk you know i can't even drink
milk anymore i'm done
why my my body just doesn't take it well
your tummy
my tummy i start [ __ ]
it sounds like that's the milk yo i've
never tried like oat milk or something
i'm on oat milk that's all i drink now
hmm
that is pretty classy he's you're
definitely
um you've done a lot of improvements to
yourself
oh yeah yeah yeah you lost a lot of
weight you're very focused on your
career
well you know you know i would i would
say your class like do you think you're
garbage
uh i had my garbage moments yeah we just
talked about how he stole from 7-eleven
every time he's in there
i mean i i haven't been to a 7-eleven
but i definitely have my but i'll go
back and steal if i need to but you
you're definitely working on it
yeah oh the thing is you're yeah of
course you're very
uh you're influenced by like you'll see
something that you didn't know like
like somebody do something and you go oh
i'll do that like for a while you're
like drinking red wine or whatever you
know what i mean
he sees somebody do something he goes oh
i'll do that like yeah
yeah i mean it's no two percent milk but
what's this avocado toast everyone's
talking about
oh i'm on it yeah yeah
and he's like oh i'm gonna do that i try
i do try more different
like way more oh man do you remember the
first time
we took you what you came to get sushi
uh well there was like 11. oh yeah at
that bar oh it was like a conveyor belt
yeah oh yeah
yeah and that time i was not dude this
was like dude this was like [ __ ]
two thousand you gotta make a decision
on those things
[Laughter]
face did he turn into a baby his face
yeah he goes i've had enough of these
japanese nuggets
and me and you want to get chicken
chicken fingers because i don't [ __ ]
with sushi
i do remember reggie staying out in
front of a [ __ ] mcdonald's
eating [ __ ] sick we went to a diner
right down the street and got chicken
fingers and fries
everybody's eating sushi but yeah at
that time i did not [ __ ] with sushi
he was so go i think it was your idea it
was like 15 of us went to get sushi
i don't like this thing yeah do you know
now you like it i'll [ __ ] it up now i
love it yeah like tuna and salmon all
that kind of stuff yeah right
i still don't [ __ ] with crab i love crab
i like crab better than lobster
i don't mean that you're talking about
the california rules the imitation crab
the crab period i don't [ __ ] with that
you don't like crab no
why i don't know i just don't like the
taste what about lobster
lobster shrimp shrimp i can eat now
i used to couldn't eat shrimp because of
the texture i just i don't know why i
couldn't catch them
[Laughter]
yo everybody a little bit family my
family loves crab
i'm like mom crabs fantastic fantastic
maybe one i've never heard anybody that
doesn't like crab unless they have a
shellfish allergy
i used to lie and say i had a shellfish
i say that i'm like i'm allergic to mayo
or whatever i don't like yeah i'm like
yeah don't put tomatoes on my sandwich
i'm allergic
yeah yeah yeah i used to say that for
years but i just never liked it
say it anywhere not even in a restaurant
i'm allergic to crap
[Laughter]
sir this is the dental office
all right um we touched on a little bit
do you currently have a suit that fits
you
like a a full body suit as you would
call it
i don't i don't own a suit you don't
want a suit no you don't you guys want a
suit i had a couple yeah
you i mean it does i bought it a couple
months ago there's no way it fits
yeah if i if i have to go if i had to
wear a suit i got to go buy it
like the next day yeah i got it yeah you
got a suit i always get hemmed up with
those
yeah damn do you have any pairs of dress
shoes do you own
one are they the ones i gave you like
five years ago
dude i used to give him all my old [ __ ]
and that was like it was a [ __ ]
if you were taking my hand-me-downs five
years ago you were in bed we were taking
them
everywhere yeah yeah i remember uh foley
gave me this black jacket he kept going
it was four thousand dollars
[Laughter]
oh he's a big barney's jacket yeah
whatever happened to that i don't
well it was three two hundred dollar
shoots together yeah
i got a picture of it in it where i'm
wearing like it's like a photo and that
was this jacket because i used to wear
it a little bit
yeah yeah this smooth black jacket yeah
it was sweet it was about 400 bucks my
brother got it at barney's yeah maybe
like 2002.
it couldn't fit him and he still was
like where's my jacket i can't fit it
it's sentimental values my brothers well
you sold it for eight bucks so it
couldn't have been
it couldn't have been that sentimental
no i gave it to them i think it was a
trade-off for the waffles i don't know
we used to wear each other's clothes off
when i lost the weight when i first lost
like a bunch of weight
everybody was still fat and you guys it
was like a yard sale
it was like everything like coming to
america
[Laughter]
i didn't wear my kippy robes every time
i showed up to a show someone was into
my jacket my pants my shoes
anytime someone had a job interview i
had to like outfit the [ __ ]
i think i think i got a pair of slacks
at the house dude we were a hot mess
oh my god you were a hot mess i feel
like you're early your whole crew
was just all seven of you were one
successful comedian yeah it was
everything we had to
[ __ ] team up and like everybody it
was hand-me-downs
yeah we were grown men
you got a suit yeah it'd be like yo i
got a job interview what size shoe were
you or whatever i need a dress shirt
[Laughter]
full circle man full circle 100
all right um have you ever hit one of
the punching bag machines at a bar
absolutely those shits are fun
that's trash have you ever ate cocktail
fruit at the bar
just out of the thing cocktail oh like a
lime or a cherry or whatever yeah yeah
the oranges
the oranges are always good at the bar
for some reason
you bite it off and then drop the peel
back in the drink
anyone in your family ever been
interviewed on the local news
but i feel like somebody would
being on the local news used to be the
[ __ ] man yeah dude
yeah you have to like you would tell
people like hey it's the six o'clock
news i'm going to be you know you see us
in the back dancing
[Laughter]
have you ever been a member of a studio
audience i was with you
yeah that just came up they brought they
were dave
not
it was it was available summer we were
standing in front of the lantern
and you had gone out and bought a new
short sleeve button down
there's a pic it's in my facebook photos
yeah and you
dude you had gotten like a haircut and
you
you pulled you got out of a cab for some
reason i don't know what this was
you took your new shirt for a ride you
got out of a cab
across the street and i could tell by
the way you got out
that you knew you were about to get
crushed
you had no confidence yeah i did
like i think that was all monroe
influenced too like i would try to
do the sneakers like there you're just a
button up shirts try to keep clean
and then y'all would just destroy me
yeah yeah we're over there wearing
[ __ ] potato sacks
it's like a [ __ ] day of the dead
that's why i still don't have confidence
in the pond
i'm looking at i'm not even around
comics
my wife will be like why don't you try
this i dude i wore a gray shirt the
other day and he was like what are you
doing
dude i don't think i'm ever wearing like
real pants again yeah i mean these
things keep [ __ ] out
i just went fast i just spent some good
money on these sweatpants i got
one great dude what brand are they they
ain't
like i got them from dick's sporting
good
headache clarify sporting good
[Laughter]
um okay um have you ever almost
fought your dad absolutely not
yeah my dad i'm still scared of my dad
i got one for all three of you in the
last 365 days have you jumped the
turnstile
i have yeah you're big on that yeah what
no
couldn't fit yeah he's got to go through
that you know or anything
like if you've seen somebody walk
through the door i don't always jump it
i'll wait till i walk through the door
i never did it i never did it yeah
because i think when i was up here
up here early
[Music]
he got busted he was up here for like
two hours he was immediately an anchor
he was immediately naked and they took
him they took him down really
oh well if i've seen that i would've i
would stop
but when three's like since corona i'll
look at the person a lot
it's corona i'm not paying for it i'm
not paying against
it's all been sanitized i look they and
it's like they don't even care
they know they understand just going
down and grab a candy bar i'll be right
back
hey you might as well buzz that door
because i ain't swiping
and grant i haven't been down here that
much but the times i come i don't pay
for
[ __ ] that's funny i remember one time
uh cotton and i were coming back from
somewhere
no towards northeast philly because we
were taking the bus
we were like editing something with the
with the guys that we were that we were
working with
and cotton's bus pass had like expired
at midnight
and it was like 12 15. and it's just a
bunch of people
going like third shift and this for some
reason this bus driver was just being a
[ __ ]
dick and cotton would not move and he
told me he's like don't you
[ __ ] dare go up there and put money
in there
and we sat there for like 20 minutes and
the guy finally just broke and he was
like [ __ ] just pulled out with us
yeah that happened at a
mega bus with me cotton dave
i i didn't have a ticket but i wanted to
leave when they left
and we went there like yo they might not
let you on you got a ticket i had it was
too late
and the driver to collecting tickets
i snuck behind them and got on the bus
was full and this lady comes like
i gotta get the word get in the morning
i gotta come on like
and the bus driver comes on he's
counting he's looking and i'm sitting
there like
and this lady's poor ladies out there
like crying and
i gotta get to work and i'm like [ __ ] i
gotta get the philly like i just
i was so scared to be left in new york
because that was like one of my first
times visiting oh yeah so scary
so i was like hey she nothing i could do
that mega bus it wasn't like we were
coming up here as human beings
yeah it's like we were coming up here as
like you know
like like gladiators or something like
that you know what i mean like yeah
being like shipped in and like
scalloping through it was scary as [ __ ]
coming up from the mega bus
and then trying to get back yeah they
dropped it over by the [ __ ] river
that's [ __ ] shady like [ __ ] 18th
avenue or whatever
halfway into the none of the lights it's
always nighttime over there
yeah just one falafel cart dude that
the bathroom on a mega bus is tough man
dude if you don't know what the mega bus
is it's a bus service that runs i think
it's a i think it's an international
company oh really
it's like if you don't know what
american airlines is oh yeah
it's funny to think of a megabus being
international
canada i think for sure it definitely
goes to canada i caught it
did you take the megabus up to jfl
if that's not the most reggie conquest
probably snuck onto that too yeah i
don't know uh i went
mid quarter that the latest but it's a
12-hour ride and just slept through the
night woke up was in montreal
good day sir definitely caught that bus
to montreal
all righty what do we got kippy where
are we at um
i don't eat dude i'm still i'm so
disoriented my head hurts from laughing
um let's do a couple more and then we'll
get out of here uh growing up was it
bagel bites or pizza rolls
pizza rolls interesting still
i still eat i'll still [ __ ] up some
pizza rolls squeeze the top squeeze
cold part in the center of your mouth
yeah yeah yeah i'll still [ __ ] with some
pizza yeah
no bagel bites all day t-bone what were
you p pizza
pizza rolls or bagel bites bagel bites
baby yeah like a [ __ ]
gentleman tortinos if we got them we
were never getting bit we were never
getting bit pizza bagels
if we had pizza bagels i feel like we
were making them ourselves and we used
to make
english muffin pizzas with american
cheese
dude there is nothing worse than a
homemade pizza bagel
it was a frozen bagel with a little bit
of pasta salt like ketchup and then a
slice of american cheese
and the american cheese wasn't fully
melted so it was still in a square
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] yeah it's
just like one day we'll get real
lunchables
[Laughter]
pizza rolls all day uh hang on this has
been a big one lately
uh domino's or pizza hut pizza
really yeah pizza for delivery now well
uh pizza huts they're done now yeah
they're either
not a lot of them i don't know what's
going on with them but you're going
dominoes now
yeah i would never like but pizza hut
was was back in the day
yeah they had the salad bar and the
stuff you get wow there was always yeah
with chocolate pudding
yeah it was great it was great pizza all
day
ain't nothing wrong with it um have you
ever worn axe body spray
yeah during the high school football
days
stinking up the place yeah right after
practice
um did you ever go to a high school
football game after you graduated
yeah that was a thing would you like
kind of try to flex on the other team a
little bit too go there like you
like you're in the hall of fame
ladies and gentlemen please rise and
welcome
you show up like you're in the hall of
fame third year
senior yeah did you wear your letterman
jacket
huh i wore my jersey to go to the game
after you graduated
yeah yep thanksgiving game i wonder you
struck out on prom you nerd
what the [ __ ] that's adorable man dude
that's cringeworthy against roman cattle
you got to show up wow look at the young
guys
you'll never beat him guys you're six
months older than him
you show up like you're in a hall of
fame like you're a kitten
coach can i talk to you it's a new coach
he's like get the [ __ ] out of here
coach i think uh let me let me try to
inspire the kids today you got a walker
and sunglasses
they didn't let us on the sideline we
were pissed we didn't
you're leaning on the fence trying to
get close
hitting on the cheerleaders we were so
mad they didn't let us on the field with
the team
like oh absolutely
god say things don't make me put the
pads on empty threats
hey rev let them boys
hey that's a bad call right that's
um all right let's do uh one or two from
um
patreon here uh guys when you sign up
for patreon we will ask your garbage
questions it's just the best way to do
it so if you want to get involved you
can sign up patreon.com so i'll show you
garbage
uh this is for mark do you or anyone in
your immediate family have a butterfly
tattoo
uh no no no butterfly tattoos okay
do they call them [ __ ] stamps no
butterfly can be a tram stamp's here
oh okay okay like well like above your
ass crap okay okay yeah nobody i know if
has a butterfly cause you got a couple
of bad ones
i got i got i got one oh i got two yeah
i got two
what is it a cross we have that tree too
yeah tree crosstalk that's
i tried to get something religious trust
so my mom wouldn't freak out but
i never got it finished and she didn't
know what it was
she'd still be oh mama it's a dream
she'll have tuned you up for that one oh
yeah she tore me up for that and my dad
because i was at a tattoo party
that's right yeah jesus yeah so
he lived a different life than h foley
tattoo party
what you went to prom and dig drugs at
uh whatever i wouldn't let somebody
stick me with a needle i'd do that
myself
putting it i'm going to get mass tattoos
all right last one this is from chris
when you replace the toilet paper roll
do you put the new roll on the dispenser
or just like leave it next to the toilet
or on the windowsill or
something on the bathtub or do you like
proper replacement
our artillery to our our our roll we got
the lift up thing
so you can just slide the slide to the
top
so you know how it's like a bar right
and you lift it up and it goes right on
i know what he's talking about easiest
[ __ ] ever it's way quicker it's a it's a
it's a
it's a stand by itself okay it's a stand
like you hit it up boom
toilet paper boom it's not that's not
what
the bathroom here goes under and it's
like this like system
and like the weight of the toilet paper
oh yeah it's tough
you're pulling on 45 little ones yeah
it's like i need a
i need a handful yeah just use the first
pass
no yeah our toilet paper thing you lift
that thing up boom put it on there
damn that's pretty fancy i don't i've
never even heard of it
he's a classy kid man he's trying i'll
give him that
try him he also didn't go to prom with
his sister that's i can't i can't
i guarantee you people are going to the
prom with their family they're not
admitting no
dude that's insane if they got stood up
it's a day or something
it's a date
did you hang out with her that night
like in like slow dance with her and all
that
no i don't remember all that
no i didn't slow dance with her she had
her she was hanging with her friends or
whatever
i was at a 12th grade prom so i didn't
really know anybody
i was in 10th grade so what the [ __ ]
were you
my sister's a loser okay that's what i'm
trying to say
at the end of the day that's what she
was hanging out with the chess club
[Laughter]
oh god all right that's it incredible
episode reggie is there anything you
want the folks out there to know do you
have coming up or
uh social media whatever social media
reg conquest
um some stuff coming out stay tuned
cool kid's gonna be a big star ladies
and gentlemen yeah big staff i love you
guys
thank you for having me of course buddy
thank you for coming coming in it's very
fun kippy what do you got for him guys
as always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube you can subscribe there as
well then patreon.com
get uh bonus content premium content all
the good stuff and then guys nashville
and raleigh north carolina will be
coming down at the end of april the 20th
and 21st get your [ __ ] tickets get
your tickets gang
get a group of friends oh yeah oh damn
yeah
i'm trying to sell support oh yeah
my mom lives in north carolina now guys
tell sheila to come on out hey hey keep
it up man
that's good for you man [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
that's good you're getting reps it [ __ ]
yeah guys so uh get some friends if
you're listening you're in the area get
some friends come out hang out
uh you'll be able to ask us questions
we're gonna be you know taking your
questions
we'll ass whatever it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be a good time we're gonna be
playing
ayg with you guys yeah we love you guys
and we'll see you next week peace
peace hang on there cowboys and cowgirls
before you go
wandering off to the range there want to
talk to you real quick just one more
time about the fun we're having
on the stereo app they have amazing
shows not just all you can listen
anytime day or night
whether you got an android or you got an
iphone you can download it and
it's for free yeah who doesn't like more
show baby more bonus more more it's a
good way to hang with us we get to
answer your question
um guys get involved every time there's
a couple hundred people in there it's a
good time for us we look forward to it
uh we'll see you there go to
www.stereo.com
wait kevin www.stereo.com
or slash h foley the link is in the
description of this episode
click that sign up we get to wet our
beaks and we'll see you there
peace